Speaker 1: Just when you think the entire
Arizona gubernatorial fiasco involving Carrie
Lake can't get any more embarrassing, Carrie
Lake yesterday was begging for money. Desperate,
desperate, claiming that she's going to fight
on despite the fact that a judge has dismissed
her final challenge in her election loss
for Arizona governor back in November. Now,
understand that it has now been seven months
almost since she lost. And when I say she lost,
it's always important to clarify. What
I mean is her opponent, Katie Hobbs,
received more votes. Judge, this this is a PBS
report from the Associated Press. Judge dismisses
Carrie Lake's last challenge in election loss for
Arizona governor. A judge on Monday dismissed the
only remaining legal claim. And Republican Carrie
Lake's challenge of her loss last year to Katie
Hobbs. Maricopa County Superior Judge Peter
Thompson said Lake failed to prove her claim
that Maricopa County did not verify signatures
on mail ballots as required by law. This was
the final challenge. So what does Carrie Lake
do? Yesterday? She holds another one of these
delusional press conferences where she comes up
with reams of paper and there's people standing
behind her. We never know who the hell these
people are or what role they have in any of this.
And then she begs for money. She begs for money.
Speaker 2: Here's one. Here's one. Dear Carrie,
my humble $20 donation for your continued
fights against the evils at the Arizona
and DC cartels. Wow. This is a $20
check. This came from Sun City West.
Speaker 1: Wow.
Speaker 2: I mean, guys, I could go through this
whole thing. This. These letters move me to tears.
Speaker 1: Yeah. The real reason she's crying
is no notes, No judges are
buying her B.S. into tears.
Speaker 2: What's going on in
our elections? And the people
are the ones who are helping us. They want. They
want our case to go forward. They want keep.
Speaker 1: Sending money.
Speaker 2: To fight this
because they know if we don't fight this now,
we're losing our country. It's not fun. I have
been offered bribes to get out of politics.
Speaker 1: There's that story which was never
verified and no details were ever provided.
Speaker 2: We have such a huge movement.
They're afraid of this movement being back on the
ballot. It's true, Bram. They're afraid of this
movement being back on the ballot. I've actually
had someone show up at my door. Pretty powerful
person offer me money to not run for office
again. They don't want my name on the ballot.
Speaker 1: They're that scared of her.
Speaker 2: So they offered me whatever I wanted
to put our movement on ice for two years.
Speaker 1: Sure. Carrie, are you
going to change funding for this effort?
Speaker 2: We are going to continue to
take donations if people can.
Speaker 1: It seems as though
you have quite literally no more legal
recourse. Are you still going to collect
donations? Absolutely.
Speaker 2: I am not
here begging for donations, guys.
Speaker 1: That's actually exact
that's quite literally what she's doing.
Speaker 2: It's difficult putting food on
the table right now in Joe Biden's
economy. It's very difficult.
Speaker 1: So I'm so let me put aside, as she
says this, she puts aside she realizes I should
stop begging for donations by taking envelopes
out of this bag of donate box of donations I
have. So she puts it to the side as she says,
I'm not here begging for donations. Well,
I guess not in the next 10 seconds.
Speaker 2: Asking for donations. I want
you to know that I am asking for people to get
involved. Marissa's going to help. We're going
to get people motivated and. Excuse me.
Speaker 1: Ballots.
Speaker 2: Excuse me just a minute.
The people who do make donations is
going toward paying for a legal fund.
Speaker 1: So you'll take them and you
have a use for them. That's great. The how would I
want to meet the person donating to Carrie Lake at
this point in time? What on earth could be going
through your mind, if anything, for you to at this
point say, hey, you know what? I think I'm going
to send Carrie Lake money. I'm going to send her
money at this point in time. I'm not here begging
for donations. I'm merely talking about how great
the people sending money are and reminding people
we will continue accepting donations. But I'm not
begging for them now, I guess, in order to
provide some cover plot, even ostensibly for
accepting donations. Carrie Lake now says she
wants to take this to the Supreme Court, where
even this delusional right wing Supreme Court, I
don't think is going to hear this case. Newsweek
reports former Arizona gubernatorial candidate
Carrie Lake on Tuesday announced her intention
to keep pushing her election case towards the
Supreme Court after suffering a major loss in
court. She made the announcement after a judge
ruled that her legal team did not have sufficient
evidence to prove ballot workers didn't conduct
the signature matching. Her challenges were
consistently dismissed in court and. Including
Mondays. But she pledged to continue fighting. She
will try to prove her argument before the Supreme
Court. She also she often makes this vague claim.
We proved our elections are a mess. We proved
signature verification is a joke. She said she
wasn't surprised by the judge's decision. Lake
also announced a new ballot chasing initiative,
which she says was the largest in Arizona. This
involves reaching out to registered voters and
assuring they submit the ballots on time. But in
the middle of all this sort of stuff. So, listen,
bottom line, this is going nowhere. This is a
complete and total human humiliation. But at the
end of the day, the only reason that these things
last as long as they do, the only reason Kerry
Lake is still doing this stuff after seven months
is because someone is donating money to her. Let
me give you a counter. Imagine a different
scenario. Imagine that on November 15th or
whatever it was that Kerry first announced that
this was going to continue for so long. Imagine
no one donated money to her. She wouldn't continue
doing this for seven months. The reason that this
continues is that people continue to donate money.
Some people clearly people who don't understand
anything. And my guess is that many of the people
sending her money can't actually afford to do so,
which is probably the saddest part of
this entire thing. So is it finally over?
Yes. And also now she's pushing for the
Supreme Court. Let's hope that doesn't happen